this next question comes under the topic
of mechanics so let's have a look at the
details together a six kilogram mass at
a so there it is hanging suspended is
held in equilibrium by two strings a b
and a
c
a b is attached to the wall and is
horizontal so you can see it going there
off to the left
ac is attached to the ceiling and makes
an angle of theta with the horizontal so
there it is there let me just mark that
in a little more clearly
the tension ac
is twice the tension in a b so there's
more pulling in this direction than in
this direction assume a gravitational
acceleration g of 10 meters per second
per second
okay part one find the value of theta
part two calculate the tensions in the
strings answer correct to one decimal
place all right so how do we go about
this and the first thing to say before i
start showing you my solution is that
the very first thing i'm going to do is
something that very few students did
which was ultra disappointing and that
is to draw a very simple force
resolution diagram uh maybe you feel
like wow this diagram is so sufficiently
simple that i don't need a special
additional diagram of my own to show
what's going on and i would respectfully
disagree which is shown by the students
who perhaps
got confused with the different angles
and how they're related to the sides
using sine instead of cosine because you
mixed up adjacent and hydrogen you saw
adjacent and opposite these are all
classic things that can be very easily
addressed and avoided by drawing just
even a simple diagram okay so let's have
a look at how we might draw a diagram
together
so this is
question 2
and we're in part a
all right so we can see here when we
have a look at this diagram right
there's these three sort of things
pulling in different directions but i
want to take um each of them and make
sure i resolve their forces so they can
be dealt with in separate ways so the
easiest force to have a look at is just
the gravitational force or the
acceleration due to gravity so i'm going
to draw that as uh from the particle
and heading down now remember the
question says it's a six kilogram mass
and gravity is 10 meters per second per
second so therefore in terms of newtons
i'm going to say well that's 6 times 10
right it's mass times acceleration so
that 6 times 10 gives me 60 newtons
going in the downward direction
then when i can say oh there's this a b
which is going horizontally towards the
wall right there's going to be some
other tension in that uh
draw a straight line like that that's a
bit better
that's going off at some particular
tension that i don't know so i'm just
going to call it t remember part two of
this question is actually to find out
what that tension is
and then lastly i've got this tension um
from the ceiling um rope or string or
whatever whatever material it is and
it's headed off at funny angle and so
therefore i am going to draw that funny
angle in but i need to resolve that
right so therefore here it goes off at
its um oopsie daisy
here it goes off at its funny angle but
i want you to remember that i've
actually got this
angle measured from the horizontal up
here in the um up here in this top
corner so you can call that an angle of
depression because you're looking from
the horizontal downward now one of the
things hopefully you remember is that
alternate angles are equal on parallel
lines so therefore an angle of
depression is the same as the
corresponding angle of elevation which
is looking from the bottom vantage point
looking up so therefore if i were to try
and resolve this into two components if
i have this kind of uh
sort of horizontal component here i
don't know why that's sort of a bit
wavy
there we go why wasn't i just using a
straight line you can see
here
this is the horizontal component of this
right it is a horizontal line so i can
measure this theta
from the horizontal and measure upwards
so that's the angle of elevation and
then i also have this corresponding
vertical part here
and it's going to be sort of you can see
there's a you know a 90 minus theta or
an uh pi on two minus theta in here
which is corresponding okay now what i
do know is that this whole
you know um rope that's going to the
ceiling it has going back to the
question uh twice the tension
than the
horizontal one
the tension in ac is twice the tension
in a b so if i call this over here t
that means that this diagonal up here is
2 t going off in that direction so this
is going to be important because it
forms the hypotenuse of this um you know
this this particular side that i have
here so i'm going to complete some of
the triangles here and you can see i've
got a slightly different color here just
so you can distinguish
so
with these right angle triangles that i
have just formed i can do a bit of basic
trigonometry and i can also use that to
reason through what is going on here
right now if you have a look at this
triangle here this triangle here you can
see that this uh this line here is of
course parallel to this one here and the
reason why this is important is because
even though this is not a good
representation of where the force is
because it's acting on the particle
itself it's equal in magnitude and
direction so therefore in vector terms
you know finding out what this is will
give me the same as what this is right
so therefore if i look in this triangle
here you can see that i can just use
simple right angle triangle trig
and say well
since a is in equilibrium right i can
say that these two forces the horizontal
one this way and the horizontal force
that way they're going to be the same
and also this force vertically and this
force from gravity which is also
vertical will be the same so that's
going to be my reasoning through this
okay so now that i've got my force
diagram i'm going to say well
if you have a look at this diagram here
cos theta is going to be this adjacent
side divided by the hypotenuse right so
if i call this x because it's a
horizontal length right
cos theta
is equal to x on 2t so therefore just x
by itself will be equal to
2t
times cos theta and like i said because
these two things are going to be
balanced with each other that will allow
me to eliminate what this t is and i am
going to solve for theta and that's
really what my goal is in part one so
let's write that down part one
i can say since a is in equilibrium
or
equilibrius if you like adjectives
the horizontal forces are balanced so
once i balance those horizontal forces i
can equate
things from the horizontal rope and also
from the horizontal component of the the
roof the ceiling room so horizontal
forces
are balanced
so therefore i can say
two t cos theta which is what i got from
that right hand um
force and then uh t which is what i get
from that left-hand force they're going
to be equal to each other i can divide
through by t because it's just it's a
non-zero quantity so not divided by zero
which is good and while i'm dividing by
t i'm also going to divide by 2 because
that's going to give me cos theta on its
own which is 1 over 2 and theta
therefore noting that theta has to be
acute because have a look at where it's
positioned in a right angle triangle
since it has to be acute the angle that
i'm going to be interested that gives
cos
to be a half is going to be pi on 3
let's stay in radians okay and i'll
reason that that's because theta is
acute
so that was part one i've found the
value of theta and i'm going to use that
for part two i'm trying to now evaluate
what the tensions in the strings are now
you can see here as i've just used the
horizontal forces what they've done is
because the horizontal forces both have
t in them um they cancel right i'm going
to need to appeal to other knowledge to
work out what t is um because you can
see here i've kind of exhausted this
option and solving here eliminates t out
of it right so i i need something which
can i can equate which doesn't eliminate
t once i sort of write the equation
together and you can see right i've
already done the horizontal resolution
of forces i'm now going to do the
vertical resolution of forces and
hopefully it doesn't take too much
reasoning to see as i was kind of
highlighting before
that this length up here let's put that
in the same color that i used here this
length here in this right angled
triangle just like i had 2t cos theta
before this vertical length is 2t
sine
theta because it is opposite here and
then there's the hypotenuse so if this
is 2t sine theta so is this which is the
force that's actually
acting on the particle
so
similarly i can say just like i made
this argument with the
horizontal forces the vertical forces
are balanced
because we're in equilibrium
so now i'm going to equate
therefore 2t sine theta
is going to be equivalent to the
60 newtons of force that are coming from
gravity right
so at this point here
you can see i'm trying to
evaluate this for t like i'm trying to
make t the subject so therefore i'm
going to
i guess i can divide both sides by 2 and
while i'm at it i actually know what
theta is because i worked it out in the
previous part it's pi on three so
therefore i'm going to write t
times sine times sine pi on three and
that's going to be equal to 30 newtons
because i also divided by two
last i checked sine pi on three is root
3 on 2 so t
is going to be
i might as well yeah i'll multiply 3.
this is 2 on root 3
times
30 newtons
and so t is just going to be equal to if
you just sort of cancel through and i
can also um rationalize the denominator
here that's going to be 20 root 3
newtons by the sounds of it and what i i
notice from the question is it says
answer correct to one decimal place so
it wants me to approximate so therefore
i can say
this t represents if you go back to my
diagram this represents the horizontal
tension here so
it's a string i do remember so therefore
tension
in string
a b
is equal to this 20 root 3 newtons but i
want that to one decimal place which i
think you'll find if you evaluate
because um
3 is like 1.7 ish you're going to get
34.6 newtons
and i also know that the tension in the
other string is double this right so i'm
going to take that 20 root 3 number
double it give me 40 root 3.
so tension in string a b is 34.6 newtons
and in string
a c
is and when you double that just be
careful um don't like round off earlier
you actually get 63.69.3
newtons and that's all to one decimal
place
okay so that was that mechanics question